this is a production of Cornell
University
okay so welcome to the grand opening of
the reborn liberty high ceiling
conservatory am Alan conver the director
of the small bit of greater plant
science and I had the honor of leading
the thanks to those who develop this
wonderful resource for our community I
will begin by thanking the Capitol
pervez managers and directors who
unfortunately could not be here they are
John dirty director state university
capital program management Scott Lewis
regional director of capital program
management and Phil panic capital
program manager for Cornell I should
note that blend Evans of the Second
World introduced acknowledge some other
people who are involved more locally
with the development
I also want to thank the Liberty High
family garden club and its president Ed
Cobb
480 stunning the wonderful plaque that
gives special meaning to the conservator
a unifying theme of the school is
discovery that connects and the new
conservatory provides a nexus for many
connections
first
in state-of-the-art design
the user of energy of agency and closer
connections between plant growth and
engineering the conservatory along with
many other important resources
maintained by the Cornell University
agricultural experiment station will be
described by Len Evans that director of
operations for the carbon station who
also acknowledged the staff who made
everything work a second speaker will
address the conservatories collection
connections that connect us with the
world of plant diversity and enable us
even in the gray code of ethic affair
aware II form a day enable us to stand
in tropical war and see the sweep of
plant evolution and look at an amazing
plant and then hold up a mobile device
and learn the life story of that plan
which is a cool thing and so Kevin next
is the chair mother conservatory
committee
and also a professor in the heart area
look at the other program will next
speak to them
elections with this
which begin with liberty high fail
has served as its first d and top it was
chair of the six history and archive
committee will address the conservatory
of history
and finally the conservatory provide a
starting point for visitors a starting
point
or plant science destinations across
campus and these include the student
designed urban Eden plantings right here
next to us and elsewhere on campus
that my Nina passers class soil monolith
collections in bradfield hall soon to
come paleobotany Fossen a fossil display
on plant science as well as the cornell
plantations and many other sites so i
invite you to explore this on your own
which you can do with the aid of this
guide available inside and with your
mobile device which you can use to open
up maps and and all sorts of other
research so for that i want to thank mag
Lindenberg and craig kramer and i also
want to thank our read we're providing
sound and refreshments and you know the
best plan so i would now like to turn it
over to play devin director of
operations for the fermentation okay so
i just want to acknowledge a few folks
and inevitably i'll miss a few but i
want to acknowledge as may as I can
we've really been instrumental across
the experiment station with really
making this structure of reality and
also you know preserving the integrity
of these 500 plus species that we have
here so it's really you know it's nice
to see where r at now I think those of
you at Cornell while you've seen sort of
the the process that it took to get to
where we are now and can probably
appreciate it better than most just how
many steps are have to go through to get
something like this into place so
there's two areas i really want to
express thanks and the first is with the
plant material so in the interim in the
absence of a conservatory while this was
being built and discussions were being
held about the future the conservatory
all that plant material had to be taken
care of
and for anybody who's ever had a
houseplant had to die well times that by
five hundred or a thousand or maybe a
bit more and that's really the the level
of complexity that our greenhouse
growers and greenhouse staff had to do
to move the plant material to care for
it to demands the pests and diseases and
really keep it in a fine shape so that
when it's new home is finally built that
everything looked really well and so I
really want express thanks we first of
all to our tower road greenhouse crew
and I know some of those are here today
we've got tray and merit we've got Josh
I want to success thanks to Paul Cooper
and in particular balls ahead greenhouse
bro and really you know throughout this
process in managing this collection and
maintaining it in the fine shape that
it's in you know his expertise has been
truly invaluable and I also want to
express sincere thanks to Melissa Breck
nur melissa is the supervisor for that
range and manages these folks as a team
you know it really takes a team of folks
to manage this plant material to keep it
keep it going and evolving just as we
like to see it the other area that
that's really been important throughout
this process has been in the structure
itself and figuring out all the bits and
pieces so that they work together
appropriately and so anybody who's ever
had a home repair I had a roof of place
or read new siding you know how things
don't always go quite the way they're
supposed to and they'd end up costing
just a tad more than maybe they should
well this structure is no exception to
that it really takes someone with a keen
eye and attention to detail and a really
a team effort to go through the entire
process of designing it putting it out
to bid having all of the contractors and
folks on the job put things in place so
that inevitably it'll be a long term
structure it will be successful and
really functional in gear to the plant
material and the teaching purposes
serves and so I think you know we've
been very successful that you know very
minor bugs left to work out at this
point and a few folks to think right
here at Cal facilities up at Kennedy
we've got a really good team of
facilities folks including Peter
paradise and Bill down in our
infrastructure properties and planning
which is they're out of our central
facilities group we've had a really good
project management throughout the
process from cad hatha tory and a tart
five and these are the guys who are
really are in and out of the project
throughout the build phase and really
making sure those bits and pieces come
together and last but certainly not
least i want to thank andy lead Andy
leaders are plant growth facilities
manager and he's just an incredible
knowledge base throughout this process
really kind of catching things in design
that would otherwise be a major issue
down and really helping to a ball to
design so as you go through the
structure you know please don't just
look at the plant material take a look
at the structure there's some really
cool features there everything from
energy saving shade curtain some sub
high efficiency supplemental lights
appropriate shades miss systems a really
sophisticated environmental control
system so all these features that have
to work together so that the plant
material is happy and so that never be
we're happy as well so with that I'd
like turn it over and what I want to say
again thanks to all those folks wouldn't
like him a round of applause Kevin Nixon
hi my involvement in this is basically
as manager and sort of generator of the
plant collection first I need to thank a
whole bunch of people first most
importantly would be Paul or Cooper I
couldn't have done anything in Eric
without Paul and he acts not only as I
was but also just announced ideas off of
in terms of how to arrange the plants
and all that kind of stuff also Devon
and Trey helped to plant this little
forest we have in here and daily will
take care of everything Melissa Andy
very important in this whole process and
I know I forgot Oh correct Craig hasn't
been mentioned yet greg has been deeply
involved in this the whole time of
course ed and I don't think this would
be standing here right now if it wasn't
for ED Carl and the students who really
put up a fight to get the conservatory
here so I think it's a really a big
community effort and my involvement goes
way back with an old conservatory but
this is we're kind of taking a new
approach here so what we're going to do
is have a very carefully managed
collection the old conservatory there
were probably six or eight different
faculty members who had some kind of
involvement so it just kind of was an
amorphous thing that went in various
directions so i am going to be the
curator and i want to take any kind of
recommendations and advice from anybody
who would like to see things go into the
conservatory in other words i'm not
going to try to restrict what's in there
but i am going to try to augment and
develop a collection that has to vary
why
earth if you will of diversity right now
we have 144 families in the conservatory
we have 347 general of plants and guess
what I forgot to count the number of
species but it's somewhere around six
hundred or more the thing is we're
numbering in the 800th right now in
terms of the accessions so one thing I'm
going to be doing is developing
connections with other conservatories
particularly the New York Botanical
Garden they're already propagating new
stuff for us to bring in so I think
we're going to have an exciting time
here of adding things my intent is to
add stuff its educational that fills a
you know that it's of interest to a
variety of people from people are
interested in evolution systematics
horticulture houseplants visitors can
see things here that they won't see
elsewhere and in that sense you will
start to see some things disappear
from the conservatory because there's no
point that's you know cultivating of the
Bonilla that you can see every time you
go to lowes so
with that said the important thing about
the conservatory from my standpoint is
that it is a biological collection and
since I'm curator of the herbarium we
already have a lot of experience in
terms of curating collections and we
have a big database structure in the
riparian and so I've kind of taken that
idea and we've developed databases and
interfaces that will allow you to
actually interface information about
this election on your cell phones or
tablets or you can do it from your
computer in your office as well some of
you are probably familiar with QR codes
so you in order to use a QR code you
need to go either to the apple store or
the android store windows phone I'm sure
there's one for Windows and then maybe
even black I don't blackberry that's one
okay but at any rate it's you can get a
free app whereby you just take a picture
basically through the app of this QR
code which
there's one on your pamphlet there and
then it will bring up the webpage and we
set up that accesses the database about
that plan that particular plan we're
just developing this some of these
aren't going to have a lot of
information yet they're going to be
expanded but for instance if you if you
do the QR code for the carnivorous
plants it actually links you to a video
showing a carnivorous plant eating a
little arthropod so there are various
things like that we're trying to add
lots of links in the information is thin
on some of these things but it will be
increasing as you go into the from the
other end and come up the center aisle
there and you're right we're just
starting to put in an evolutionary
sequence for land plants that goes from
liverworts Tanja's firms along that side
but we still are missing some things we
need some different like opposed
so we're working
so I don't know that there's much
outside like to say again I'd like to
thank everybody who's involved and has
been involved and will be involved in
any students who want to get involved
we're always looking for people who want
to work in the conservatory Oh which
means I forgot to pay Nick and Patty who
are the ones that you'll see in there
you'll see them we have it set up now so
they can actually enter data through
their cell phones and so it's a good
reason they just hang out now down here
entering data and so for instance
there's a little lap they can enter data
so every time they go through they check
that not every time but often they'll
check to see what's in flour and they
can just hit a little button sets out to
the flour so how many things do you
think are in flower right now daddy
knows 34 in 134 is that what it is I
thought of ringers so they're 134 plants
in here well if you were in the purple
house but most of them right here it had
flowers on them right now you might look
sometimes they're hard to see some
plants don't ever contracted flowers so
at any rate I'm very happy to be here
and I'm hoping it will be able to really
develop this into something great thank
you very much
so our next and final speaker is then
come up concern as to the meetings and I
always wonder by the historians Club his
paper actually read your statement
so we used everyone where you could come
today but his wife saw me whether pretty
good you know it's not raining not
really if it's a nice warm in the
greenhouse we'll be there sir ok so we
have been for conservatory green houses
built on the Cornell campus the first
conservatory was built in eighteen
eighty two and was attached to the
botany we of sage college a small a
conservatory was built near this site
just this way in 1909 it was designed to
house tropical plants for the new
college of agriculture in 1931 another
conservatory was built on this exact
site when plants and the plant science
building was constructed construction on
the conservatory but Mars today was
completed in late 2015 during Cornell's
sesquicentennial year yes he got truth
because it's one of the two buildings
that can be locked in for 22 feet
husband klarman all so Liberty hi Bailey
the first dean of the still very active
college of agriculture was involved in
selecting the curved glass design of the
previous conservatory constructed by
Lord burner starting in the 1920s Bailey
traveled extensively collecting and
studying pumps some of the very first
plants that were moved into
the new conservatory in 1931 four pounds
and we even have with last slide frozen
yeah it shows the lab with a [ __ ]
sexual the previous me know so the
plants were moved in the new
conservative a third one which we palms
as we know requires special conditions
especially for survival in Ithaca
hospital winters research on palm
anatomy and pump taxonomy continued in
the structure for over 75 years with
plants being maintained in this
conservative so today this is a grand
day for Cornell and the plant sciences
we have many people to thank for the
state of our state of our structure
after over 75 years of continuous use
plans were drawn up for renovation or
rebuilding of the previous Liberty
hidebound conservatory however in the
fall of 2010 it was announced that it
was to be torn down and not replaced
physically on this site this resulted in
a grassroots movement within the Cornell
community to save the conservatory in
this location for easy access by
students and the community Heather Holly
president of orders form at the time
circulated a petition to restore the
conservatory or have it rebuilt in this
location within less than a week over
800 members of the photo community
signed the petition
and during the time Carol Bader I want a
long time caretaker of the conservatory
blot brought the plight of the structure
to the attention of President David
Skorton who eventually influence the
decision and saved our conservatory at
this site
it's my home in the hope of everywhere
the proper care this conservatory and
the collection of plants contain within
will survive into the next century for
the benefit
generations to come
Kevin in plant from healthy
yeah open this up
yeah this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu